depuis les annonces du gouvernement
michèle trémeau ne décolère pas
cet apiculteur gère près de 400 ruches
dans la région et plus de la moitié de
sa production se faire au miel de fleurs
et donc à proximité des cultures pour
lui réintroduire les néonicotinoïdes
serait une catastrophe
c'est des produits où on a multiplié
molécules au carré et pour vous dire
dans le temps on a entendu parler du ddt
c'est des produits qui sont on va dire
400 350 à 400 fois plus toxique quand la
plante va fleurir
on aura des traces d'un insecticide dans
les pollens et l'hectare donc on a des
nectars des pollens qui sont peu élevés
une décision d'autant plus mal vécue car
depuis l'interdiction de ces
insecticides systémiques en 2018
l'agriculteur avait remarqué le retour
d'une faune jusque là absente
je pense que le côté positif masse et
qu'on a une une recrudescence de
pucerons et pour moi qui est agriculteur
hors sol c'est une bénédiction alors
c'est sûr que je comprends bien que pour
mes collègues céréaliers c'est une
catastrophe
ce sont ces pucerons vecteur de la
jaunisse que les betteraviers veulent
éradiquer aujourd'hui mais en apiculture
les pucerons
en creusant de micro trous dans les
arbres permettent à la sève de couler
cette sève est ensuite utilisée par les
abeilles pour faire le miel michelle
fremaux vont chaque année 5 tonnes de
miel en vente directe une production
fragile qui a tendance à diminuer au fil
des années à l'heure actuelle on arrive
à des productions en france 12 15 mille
tonnes alors qu'on était à 35 milles
tonnes avant les insecticides
systémiques
donc c'est moi pour moi c'est une des
causes majeures des néonicotinoïdes
pourrait être ré autorisé pour les
betteraviers dès l'automne prochain et
la nouvelle fait déjà des émules dans
une annonce du 7 août les producteurs de
maïs demandent le même régime de faveur